hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
liposomes for drug delivery and
targeting examples of their potential
from our laboratories research presented
by Sophia Ann Timothy ARS
professor Unova University of Patras in
the Institute of chemical engineering
4th IC e HT hi I'm Alexis Corrales of
labyrinth and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by laberd's lab roots is the
leading scientific social networking
website at producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your question into
the drop down box that appears on the
screen once there's many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the help desk button located in the
promotional board at the bottom center
of your screen or use the ask a question
box to let us know you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the
accreditation button located in
promotional board at the bottom center
of your screen and follow the process to
obtain your credit please join me in
welcoming dr. intimacy r's and i will
now turn the presentation over to her at
the presentation as you already heard
the title is liposomes from poor drug
delivery and targeting examples of their
potential from our research results and
you already heard where I am from just a
bit of an introduction about the
University of Patras and the Institute
of chemical engineering which is part of
the forth Institute to the larger
sensitivity in Greece we are located in
Paris which as you see in the map is in
the central part of Greece on the side
towards Italy and these are a few
pictures from the area where our
University and our Institute is located
the outline of my talk is seen over here
initially I will talk about the
advantages of nanotechnologies in
general compared to conventional
formulations
what is the advantage that we get out if
we administer drugs in the form of
nanoparticles or nanomedicines it's
really called them compared to the usual
formulations that we know then we will
focus on liebe somes and talk about
potential applications with examples
from the work that we have been doing in
our laboratory in the last 20 maybe
years so let's go on with the first part
about the advantages of ver nano
technologies compared to conventional
formulations when we administer
conventional formulations we usually get
fluctuations in the concentration of
drug in the serum and in the organs
where we want the drugs to show their
pharmacological action so this may not
be very good for the therapeutic effect
and in many instances we want to control
the release from the formulation in
order to have better results also when
we administer conventional drugs what we
get is that the drug after it is abroad
in the blood are distributes to all the
parts in the body are depending on the
physical chemical properties and the
size of the molecule and this means that
it will end up eventually in the size of
action but also in other tissues where
it may cause toxicity and side effects
so if we somehow could administer the
drug in the form of nanotechnologies we
can have several advantages as you see
they may be protection of sensitive
molecules from areas in the body where
the molecule may be destroyed controlled
release and also targeting to the
specific site that we want to the drug
to go to
this way will have increased from a
logical activity and decreased toxicity
just a brief introduction about what
none of technologies in general are they
are not particles usually in the form of
spheres or capsules their size is about
10 to 200 nanometers if they are around
this is the diameter and they can be
loaded with active drugs they can
control the release rate of the drug and
they can transfer the drug to specific
targets in the body assuming that they
have some targeting moiety under surface
there are different types of
nanoparticles one of these types is the
label source and the structure and the
ingredients may vary they may be
polymeric they may be a little bits they
may have a structure of capsules or
spheres they may have other structures
such as dendrimers or micelles and they
may also be composed of inorganic
materials but of course in this case
there are several problems where we want
to apply them for delivery of drugs so
what are the requirements that we need
our nanotechnologies to have in order to
be used for drug delivery as you can see
here they should be I should be possible
that we can load them with adequate
amount of active drug as higher the
loading the higher the loading the less
the amount of nanoparticles that we have
to use so this also may have an effect
on the toxicity of the particle that we
use it has to be easy to modify the Nano
carrier surface because the surface is
very important for the actual result
because this is what the body sees they
have to be non toxic non immuno genic
by degradable and by compatible and all
of these of course depends very much
and the dosage we administer so if we
can have high loading of the drug we can
have high drug concentrations with a
lower amount of nano material and this
means that we have we can have a lower
dose and minimize the chances of
toxicity and problems with
biocompatibility also we have to be sure
that the drug is retained in the
nanoparticle until the biological target
is reached and we have to be sure that
it will be actually released when it
reaches the site when it has to act so
all of these are important and as I
already pointed out loading and those
are two characteristics that are very
important for and determined let's say a
possibility to use any type of
nanotechnology for drug delivery and now
we will go to the second part because we
will focus on liposomes
in the last twenty and so years we are
working there our lab with lipizzans
so I will try to convince you that this
is the best system to use when you want
to deliver drugs and then I will show
you a few examples from our team's
research about their potential
applications so first of all let's see
what lipophilic are and let's talk about
their advantages and potential
disadvantages now as you can see in the
cartoon on the top of this slide lipid
shows are actually composed of lipids of
a lipid bilayer it's something like a
cell membrane the lipids are
phospholipids and they have an aqueous
entrapped Center where we can load
hydrophilic drugs or other type of
particles if we need to so the person
baggage is that we can have high loading
efficiency and we can load any type of
drug because we can have lipophilic
drugs in the membrane or hydrophilic
drugs in the aqua center another very
important parameter and advantage is
that they are non-toxic fully
biodegradable and biocompatible not a
butyl Janek because they are actually
composed of phospholipids and
cholesterol may be which are the main
ingredients of ourselves and they are
very versatile so we can easily change
the surface as we want to perhaps we
want to add something on the surface
that will direct the lipid song to the
specific part in the body so it's easy
to do this we'll do the persons because
of the versatility of the chemistry of
the lipids
also they have ability to modulate the
release of their active molecules by
different triggers if we want to or by
simply modulating the lipid membrane
composition and I will show you some
examples further down one disadvantage
if we want to really be strict is that
the amount of time that a drug can be
retained in lipizzans may be shorter
than the time that we have in other
types of nanotechnology like polymeric
amount of technologies nevertheless
these disadvantages can be overcome by
construction of hybrid systems and I
will show you a few examples further
down in this talk so going on I have to
point out that when we talk about
ribosomes we can categorize them in four
different main classes corresponding to
their ability to transfer drugs so we
may have conventional episomes which are
typically composed phospholipids with
nothing under surface the problem with
these types of liposomes is that they
end up very fast in the liver and spleen
after we inject in the body and this is
because they are taken up of myvar' es
of the and the immunological system the
macrophages in care and general
and this way potential to use this type
of liposomes for drug delivery is very
limited because we can only reach the
macrophages and this is called passive
targeting in this case if we want to
reach other sites in the body we have to
have the persons that circulate for
longer in our blood and in order to do
that we have to have under surface a
specific type of molecules like polymers
or sugars that will make the surface
hydrophilic and this way the little salt
will avoid to be taken up by macrophages
and will circulate for longer in the
bottom and this gives them chances to
reach other sites as cancer tumors for
instance the third type is a targeted
lipizzans in this case we want to have a
targeting ligand that will target
specifically our little sum to a
specific cell type in the body and the
last type is a cationic de personnes
which are usually used when we want to
deliver our genetic material because
there is a possibility to connect the
genetic material with a cationic lipids
I will not be talking about cationic
lipids ohms and gene delivery today
because the examples I will show you are
more general examples or drug delivery
conventional drug delivery let's say
okay so let's go on to the next slide
and now I'm going to go into the third
part about the potential applications of
liposomes I will show you how we can use
labels to simply protect active
molecules from areas in the body where
they may be degraded so inactivated in
other words or vice-versa we we may want
to protect the body cells from drugs
that
cytotoxic and high concentration so I
will show you some examples about this
first of all now to protect the body
from very active drugs or toxic drugs we
may use this type of nanotechnologies we
may use liquor forms or other type of
nanoparticles this is an example about
the reduction of cytotoxicity every
pharmacy and refurbishing these are
quite toxic drugs so if when it reaches
avail ourselves it has some cytotoxicity
this has been done in my lab some years
ago and we can see in the graphs on the
left side that the viability of the
cells is lowering as we increase the
concentration of the drug the columns
that are white are free drugs correspond
to the free drug while the other columns
correspond to different types of
nanoparticles were composed of polymers
in the top graph and little somes
different types of lipids in the bottom
graph so we can see that as we increase
the concentration of the drug we have
more cytotoxicity when it's increase
form but if we have it encapsulated in
polymeric particles or in ribosomes we
can have a very high reduction of the
cytotoxicity so we can administer high
concentration of drug without having the
toxicity now second example shows us the
opposite how we can protect a specific
drug from the environment that it goes
into when we administer in vivo in this
case we are talking about we are showing
the example of
cumin cumin is degraded in aqueous
solutions very fast you can see in these
two graphs the black line the bottom
line with the squares is free coca mean
when we put it in serum at different two
different concentration 0.01 milligram
per ml and 0.05 on the right so we can
see how much how fast cumin the grades
when we add cocoa bean in different
types of episodes we can protect it and
we see then we can compose we can
prepare liposomes that protect the drug
and this way we can administer our the
drug and have it in an active form for
longer periods of time so we expect also
a higher form of illogical action now
the second thing I'm going to show you
examples about is how we can control the
release rate of drugs when we administer
in the form of lipizzans I already
pointed out in the beginning that may be
a disadvantage of liposomes is that they
cannot retain drugs for very long
periods of time this of course depends
on the drug properties I will show you
to start out this example where I'm
showing you here on the left side shows
two different type of lipizzans
so we can see that we can change
especially for such large hydrophilic
molecules we can control their release
very very nicely and we can change the
release kinetics and by using different
types of lipizzans actually what we are
doing is we are using different lipid
membrane compositions so we have in the
one case non-saturated lipids and in the
other case saturated literature and we
can see how we can control very nicely
the release
and for several days over here have very
low release or faster if you want now if
we have a smaller molecule like calcium
I I don't feel it and you can see this
these results on the on the left side
excuse me on the right side you see that
they are it is released faster because
the time is in hours now in mavin days
and again we can control the release
depending on the little film composition
that we use and in the middle graphs you
see the retention actually this is not
the release it's very tension of
dexamethasone which is most more
lipophilic drug so it is released also
pretty fast from liposomes but again we
can use different types of lipizzans and
control the release of course we cannot
control the release for months and in
this case if we want to have a longer
release we can use different types of
hybrid systems so I will show you three
examples three types of hybrid systems
the one is a dragon-cycle dex turn and
then in the ozone system the other is to
put our little formal drugs in gels and
the third one is to actually mobilize
our lipizzans
and surfaces of biomaterials in order to
produce drug eluting biomaterials
in this way we can also control the
specific area in the body where our drug
is released and we can have a different
mode of release depending on the
lipizzans that we use okay let me go and
show you now our example specific
examples for each one of these cases
let's go to the first one why would we
need to have the drug it's a collection
in little subsystem to make long story
short in some cases when
druggist lipophilic or amphiphilic it
actually has a possibility it has a
capability to permeate the little formal
membrane so if it's somehow partitioned
between the lipid in the aqueous phase
at the time that we inject it or we
administer to the body and it reaches
the blood because of the dilution it is
very diluted so some of the drug is
released from the liver form and
saturates the extra a solution that is
available the extra water that is
available in the system so we we very
fast very rapidly lose a lot of the
encapsulated molecules of drugs so in
this case what we can do and this was
proposed several years ago by the group
of Gregorius we can actually have a
complex of our drug with a cycled actual
molecule this complex with psycho
addiction are molecules that have our on
imperialism a form like a capsule with
lipophilic and interior and a
hydrophilic surface so our lipophilic
drug will go in the capsule it will form
a complex and exterior of the cavity and
once I computed cavity is hydrophilic so
this way we can increase the solubility
of a drug and actually encapsulated in
the center in the aqueous base of the
liver foams and this way it is more
stable II encapsulated in the little
jumps we have done this work in our
laboratory with producer alone and with
coke amine and in the complications that
appear on the end of these slides you
can see if you want to you can go to
these publications and see what we what
we also can have compared to the plain
lipizzans and say
when the drug is just partitioned
between the acura center and the
membrane face another case I was going
to talk about is about drug and liquid
salts in gels so if we have a small drug
in a gel system it may be released very
fast
one way to ink to decrease the release
rate is to encapsulate the drug first in
the lipizzans as you see in the body and
then in the bottom of our cartoon and
then in a gel this way we have two
diffusion rates one of the drug to
release from the liver some and then
from the jar and this way actually we
have a slower release so we can control
the release from such lipophilic gels
and have a more prolonged retention of
the drug in our gels when the drug is
initially entrapped in the liposome and
then this little formal drug is
dispersed in the gel so here you see
what we have this was work that we did
in the content of a European project
some years ago and on the left hand side
we have the plain gels with the drug
inside and on the right hand side we
have the lipid soldier so we see if we
put them together that okay the release
is followed when we have the little
former gel and on the bottom you can see
that we can control the release rate by
feeding our system with different amount
of lipizzans
so it's very easy to work with way and
have a more prolonged release from
aleppo so Michelle compared to the
control job this is one example we have
a second example here where we can
control actually the release of drugs
from liposomes by incorporating these
liposomal drugs in
else that our thermals also ph-sensitive
in this case so this is work that we
published in 2011 you can see the
reference in the bottom of the slide and
you can see in the right hand side there
is a graph which shows the release of
the drug from playing episodes or the
release of the drug when we have
lippisch ohms
incorporated in this polymer we can
adjust the weight of the polymer the
concentration of the polymer and have a
different release rate and actually we
have a zero order release which is very
important to get constant concentration
in the blood so this is a very nice
example of what we can do with fetch are
lipophilic gels and let's move on and
see another casework from a very recent
workout that we have been doing with in
collaboration with a group from the
University of Crete what we wanted to do
is to sustain the release of small
non-steroidal non-steroidal
anti-inflammatory drug should be profam
after intramural injection in the eye so
we can see that the drug is very fastly
released from the gel when it's free
it's very the black line shows us how it
can be retained when we added in a
polymer and when we make a hybrid system
with the Lipscomb's in the polymer we
have the red where we see that we can
control the release and have a sustained
release for a very long period of time
the plain lipizzans do a good job but
not so good and that is the are the
green line in our graph so we can see
that we can increase your
residence time on the bottom you can see
the pharmacokinetic parameters and also
the way you see that we have individuals
and of course we also have very good
results in the retina and if while if
one wants to see more about this you can
see it in the reference that I quote
over here I work that we just published
our last year so going God the third
let's say hybrid little subsystem that I
talked about is the drug eluting
biomaterials we have done several
different cases in one case we
immobilized little films on polymeric
materials from polymer coated stents and
you see in the picture on the left hand
side the lip of songs attached actually
adsorbed and the polymer they look like
lines okay so you can see the lipids in
there and we can control the release of
the drug by using different type of
Nicholson's and you as you can see in
the in the graph on the top and this was
done just by simple adsorption of the
liver shows on the material of the stand
under polymer graph extent but we also
moved on and we found out that we can
immobilize new persons on playing metal
surfaces after we grabbed specific
functional groups groups on the surfaces
with plasma technology so these plasma
treated surfaces were possible to
interact with functionalized ribosomes
that we prepared and in the liposomes we
had put heparin and this resulted in a
very significant increase of the
biocompatibility of the material now you
can see the
compatibility graph on the bottom where
the blue column shows the case where we
have the label shows attached covalently
on the surface of the materials and
having heparin inside the heparin it is
released and therefore the
biocompatibility the Hema compatibility
of this material is very much increased
we also did the same a similar thing to
produce antimicrobial surfaces by using
two promising lipizzans
which were immobilized on the surface of
catheters so you can see here in blood
both graphs the case where the combs are
very low are actually the cases where
the catheters were coated with these
lipizzans and which had to Brahmas in
inside so bacteria could not approach on
these surfaces actually what we measure
here is the amount of bacteria that are
forming on the surface of these
catheters and we all know that this is a
problem so this is an example of what
the person can do to produce
antimicrobial surfaces and this again
was published in 2015 now let's move on
to the last part the last part I think
is the most important and the most
challenging and it's actually about
targeting okay what can we target with
ribosomes we can target more or less
everything but I will show you now some
examples from our work about targeting
cancer cells or cancer tumors are
biological barriers such as a
blood-brain barrier which is the most
challenging and most important barrier
in our body I think and also we can also
target specific
Pathology's related with diseases such
as the amyloid plaques in Alzheimer's
disease so I will show you some examples
from work that we have done years ago or
recently first of all let's talk a
little bit about cancer
I will go very fast if you don't know a
lot about this I think you would have to
find the reference and understand more
about it but to make it very short in
cancer there is a phenomenon that is
called EPR for enhanced permeability and
retention effect and this means that the
valve because of the very fast
angiogenesis in the cancer cells the
vasculature that is form is very leaky
so if we have lipizzans or any type of
nanoparticles that are very small and
circulate in our blood for long periods
of time eventually they will extrapolate
in a tumor if if there is a tumor around
because of the leaky vasculature so
because of also the very low lymphatic
system they are actually trapped there
so they can release the drug this is why
we have very good performance of Lipitor
drugs for several types of cancer but we
have to be sure that we are preparing
our little subs in the correct way
first of all we have to have a very good
polymeric coating on the surface so they
will be able to circulate for a long
period of time or B in other words we
call this self so they have to be very
still and also we have to be sure that
if we are having a targeting ligand to
specifically target a specific component
on the surface of the cells like a
protein which is overexpressed there we
have to be sure that the ligand that we
add is on the surface of the ribosome
and it's not blah
ah by the polymer coating so it's
important how we prepare our Nicholson's
here I show an example targeting 52
cells in the liver by using the performs
that have under surface on a shelf a
tween targeting ligand this ligand will
target the galactose receptors which are
overexpressed on these cancer cells so
as we increase the distance between the
ligand and the surface of our episodes
as we go from the top to the bottom in
these graphs here
we see that the targeting we get in the
cells compared to the control cells
which are the black symbols the white
ones are the amount of ribosomes that we
get in the target cells we increase the
targeting actually so when we prepare
our lipizzans in a great way and this in
vitro setup we saw a very good in fact
of course when we go in vivo there is
also a bad so good and this is why we
don't have today anything on the market
which is targeted this is something very
important at the time now going to the
blood-brain barrier we have there we
have done a lot of work through the last
years and this was within fp7 a European
project it was funded by Europe it was
in collaboration with many other labs
and we have published a lot about this
and you can see the publication's over
here so what we have done is we prepared
liposomes using one ligand to target one
receptor on the blood-brain barrier
and another ligand to target another
receptor and when we have both ligands
on the same lipizzans we see on the top
graph we see the Arctic by specific
blood-brain barrier
endothelial cells and we see that the
black one is the control lipizzans with
nothing under surface simply regulated
lipizzans
with a polymer that will make them
circulate for long and as we add one
ligand or another ligand we have a an
increase compared to the non ligand
liposomes and when we add both this is
the green color we see that we have a
better effect compared to the liposomes
that have one are they got darker
surface and we have the same results we
have the same results when we check this
how these lipid foams
transport across a cell one layer
[Music]
cellular model of a broadband barrier so
if you want more details you can find
them in these publications but let me go
on saying that we also did a lot of vivo
experiments with this system and we saw
the same effects if we have one ligand
we have a little bit increase if we have
the other ligand we have again similar
increase but if we have both ligands the
red line in the graph on the right hand
side we see that we have a best results
and we see this actually in the brain of
the animals my last animal we see the
signal in the in the head is very much
increased because it has it is really
performed with both a blow of the
linkage how the surface in this after we
finish this work we are continuing I
work now
the potential for targeting the brain
with a little salt by using by getting
some influence from the organic traffic
properties of extracellular vesicles or
exosomes this is work that we are doing
now and we hope to have even better
results here now let's go on and talk
about the third part of targeting
actually how we can target specific
pathological features and in this case
what we wanted to target was the amyloid
plaques or actually the ingredients have
we actually allow of the amyloid clubs
with which our amyloid peptides in the
brain and in order to find a solution or
a therapeutic or diagnostic system for
Alzheimer's disease and again this
research was funded by the same project
that I talked about before so what we
try to do here is I find specific
ligands that we can put on the surface
of our episodes in order to target these
amyloid peptides or amyloid species in
general we use different types of cumin
because from the literature it was know
that curcumin can have some affinity for
a better peptides so we synthesized two
types of cocoa bean derivatives and we
immobilize them on the surface of
episodes and we found out actually that
these nipple songs have very high
affinity for different types of amyloid
species so they were also able to have
an effect on the aggregation of amyloid
peptides amyloid peptides aggregate they
form the plaques and the plaques
responsible or the oligomers of the
plaques are responsible for the toxicity
that is demonstrated and the pathology
has demonstrated in in Alzheimer's
disease
so these lipizzans were actually able to
decrease the rate of aggregation of
amyloid peptides and they were also able
to as we see in the in the right hand
side in the top to stain eye amyloid
plaques from brain slices post mortem of
our most hybrid disease patients and
they also had the possibility to lower
the toxicity of a better peptides
towards specific types of our neural
cells so we thought that these liposomes
could be able to target ala Alzheimer's
disease and we at the end what we did is
that we prepared episodes that are
multifunctional in terms that they have
ligands to target both the brain because
they have to pass the brain to get the
blood-brain barrier to get into the
brain and also the amyloid plaques so
when we are added all of these ligands
on the ribosome surface we see or on the
cartoon on the left side we have three
ligands now in fact we didn't see any
difference in their ability to target
the brain on the bottom graph we see
this result from our vitro cellular
system the mono layer system the
transport is the same for now
ribosomes that have only the blood-brain
barrier targeting ligands and the ones
that have also began to target the
amyloid plaques and when we administer
these in wild-type well
nice and in Alzheimer's disease model
mice double transgenic mice to this case
we see that the amount of the lipizzans
that end up in the brain are much higher
and transgenic animals and the Abscam
earth disease one compared this is a red
line okay compared to the wild-type
animals that don't have amyloid plaques
in the brain so perhaps this is because
of the animal parts of course we need to
do more work to prove this at the end so
but this is a very good result for the
time so I hope from here that we can
conclude we can come to the conclusion
part of this presentation so I hope that
I convinced you about the advantages of
the technologies compared to
conventional formulations I hope a
complete see about proportions and what
they can do the limitations to control
drug release and how we can fix it with
hybrid systems and also how we can use
the potions for specific applications
when we want to increase protection of
drug molecules this is a simple
situation when we want to decrease the
size of toxicity of large concentration
of drugs or when we want to increase the
targeting the specific cell types cancer
cells biological barriers or
pathological sites over or molecules
like the amyloid species and here I have
to come to the acknowledgement of all
the contributors in this work that I
showed today most of the people are from
my lab I have here very many previous
and recent researchers working in my lab
also from the University of Arthur's
there are other colleagues and I
collaborate with my professor puppet
scientist professor stucco polish
proficiency license to Yanis and also
from the University of Crete proficiency
T antivirus and his group and several
groups from abroad of that contributed
in some of the research that I showed
today and some of them is also special
today so you all see them here and I
want to thank you for your attention
thank you dr. Anton the CRS for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click the send button well answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for so let's get started our first
question is which route of
administration can be used for liposome
drug formulations uh yeah we can use
different different routes of
administration now but of course you
will see in the literature
mostly sometimes ministers IV
intravenously but they can work very
well also for protocol administration or
her local administration there are
different types of lipizzans that can be
used for transdermal delivery of drugs I
didn't get into that in my presentation
although we have worked on it so the
only problem with ribosomes is that you
cannot have a very stable lipizzans in
the GI tract because of the colic acid
in the in the GI tract so that's the
only route that is not very possible for
little sense our next question is are
there liposome formulations in clinical
use as drug products today which drugs
are currently available in life of some
form in the market
yeah there are many drugs
market first ones that appeared and are
already in generic formulations are dr.
Robeson which is an anti-cancer drug and
potassium B these two drugs have very
good results and you know mostly because
with the lipitor formulation the
pharmacokinetics is changed so this
means that the drug eventually ends up
in different areas in the body and we
have very significant decrease in their
toxicity these drugs are very toxic so
this way we can increase the dose
without having the toxicity and this
means that we have a better
pharmacological action and a very good
result so there are several drugs on the
market today and FDA has approved for
several are usually mostly for several
types of cancer
which is the advantage of the current
life of some drug products and what is
the theoretical background that explains
their advantages compared to the
corresponding conventional formulations
this is connected with the previous what
I said before these formulations that
are on the market today mostly work
because they decrease the toxicity of
the drug because of the change
modulation of the pharmacokinetics
compared to the pharmacokinetics of a
free drug and this is the theoretical
basis so today we don't have any
targeted drug formulation because our
drug formulation on the market but
mostly passively our targeted
formulations and this is why most of the
formulations are for cancer I really
explained about the EPR effect in my
presentation so this is actually the
theory behind most of the existing
reform of yours on the market what are
the current challenges in the field of
nano medicines for drug delivery current
challenges are related to this that we
don't have a targeted formulation of any
drug with little somes
on the market today although there has
been a lot of research during the last
25 or 30 years with very good in vitro
in some cases also in vivo results in
animal studies there is no translation
to market a product for clinical use
mainly because the difference if we have
between my little shows and the targeted
episodes is not yet so good to advance
to this type of formulation the other
big challenge is of course to be able to
cross biological barriers and
most important of course is the brain
the blood-brain barrier so these two
challenges are very very important and I
would add also another challenge would
be to have a formulation that can
actually deliver illegal nucleotides in
order to get the advantages of this type
of therapeutics in the eval clinic and
it looks like we have time for one more
question do such nano technologies have
applications in other fields such as
cosmeceuticals food products etc of
course of course there are many
applications
episomal formulations it's a super soma
encapsulated enzymes or little soma
capsule made active materials that could
be also integrated in cosmeceuticals
or food products ripening of cheese is
something that can be done with people
formal enzymes there are several
examples of the use of ribosomes in
non-medical let's say fields so it's an
attractive methodology to use also for
for other types of another areas where
you want to control the release of a
specific agent from a specific
formulation I would like to once again
thank you dr. insistence ers for her
presentation I would also like to thank
lab rats for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through May of 2018 you will receive an
email from labyrinth letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that in out
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon goodbye